[Applause]
and you know ask you a question and
don't google it what's the biggest
agricultural power in Europe who is the
biggest food exporter in the entire
European Union how many of you might
think Spain Italy or maybe even France
after all these countries have good
weather and thousands upon thousands of
hectares of arable land none of these
countries though comes close to the
Netherlands also known as Holland to
give you a better idea the Netherlands
is almost the largest food exporter in
the world second only to the United
States and this is kind of a surprise
because we're talking about a country
here that is so small they have to build
dams to reclaim land from the sea in
fact it's one of the most densely
populated countries in the world to this
we need to add the fact that they are
one of the richest and most modern
countries on the planet the first stock
market was created in Amsterdam and I'm
sure all of you know Dutch companies
like shell Phillips or the bank IMG
[Music]
normally when a country has many
industrial or service companies
agriculture is placed on the back burner
so now you might be wondering well why
why is the Netherlands such a big food
producer well imagine that we have a
piece of land for example say in Spain
that measures one hectare if you use it
to plant potatoes we can earn between
7,000 and 8,000 euros per hectare
imagine instead the amount of money that
we could earn if we use that area to
build a factory or an office building
when you do that kind of math it quickly
becomes clear why countries move away
from agriculture well despite all of
this Holland is the world leader of
potato exports above France above Spain
above even the USA
[Music]
and now I can probably guess what
something you're thinking agriculture in
Europe
I mean Brussels has got to be giving out
grants somewhere right agriculture is
indeed one of the most protected sectors
with the most aid in the entire European
Union however the Netherlands is in the
country that receives the most money of
course they receive aid like any other
member country but they don't even get a
third of what Greece gets and if we
compare it with larger countries like
France the difference in aid is huge so
how is it possible that with so little
land and so little help Holland has
become the Garden of the world
[Music]
but as you can imagine the answer is
simply explained in one word technology
in a farm in the Netherlands we can find
tractors that drive themselves drones
that monitor crops and of course
resource optimization at the highest
level however there's still a question
here
why does Holland have more modern
agriculture than for example Spain also
what is the Netherlands done that can be
imitated in other countries well today
we're going to answer these questions
but before we do let's take a look back
at the history
[Music]
from the field to the University in the
1970s Holland had one of the most
prosperous economies in all of Europe
companies such as Philips and Airbus
were conquering the international market
and all of this was great news for the
Netherlands but as we always say on
visual politic not everything was a
field of races imagine being 20 years
old and living in the Netherlands back
then where would you have liked to work
in an international company like Philips
with high salaries and good conditions
or on your father's farm well exactly
Dutch agriculture it was on the verge of
disappearing and we also have to add
something very important to this as we
said before the Netherlands is very
small and there's hardly any space for
large farms
[Music]
now for example there's plenty of land
in the United States and that means that
farmers can group and create a large
farm in fact today a lot of american
farms belong to large corporations this
means that they can scale investments
and buy for example planes to fumigate
huge areas of lands however in the case
of the netherlands farms are small with
an average size of around seven hectares
making large investments really very
complicated to make matters worse by the
70's dutch salaries were already much
higher than in other european countries
in other words unlike the farmers in
southern italy the dutch couldn't
compete with low prices and you might be
wondering now why did they need
agriculture
[Music]
after all in those years there was
already a certain degree of
international trade the Netherlands
could imports food while they
manufacture televisions or airplanes
right well yeah that that is right and
from a purely economic point of view
they could have easily let go of their
primary sector well the reality is in
life not everything is just the economy
and in Holland farming associations have
a lot of power more so than in pretty
much every other country for example in
many other countries they have something
called the social dialogue table which
is an organization where the government
employers and unions meet on the
Netherlands they have something similar
along with employers and unions farmers
and ranchers associations are also well
represented
[Music]
and in the 1970s Dutch farmers and
ranchers weren't willing to change jobs
so consider yourself put in this
situation Holland's had to maintain its
primary sector at all costs so at the
same time all of the odds were stacked
against them at this point I know you
must be thinking they did grants the
solution would be to simply give
subsidies to farmers so they'd stop
protesting right
[Music]
I mean this wouldn't exactly be the
first or the last time that such
policies have been applied but the Dutch
government they actually had other plans
now that they had to maintain their
primary sector they wanted to do it well
and since they couldn't reduce salaries
or group farms there was only one
solution left and I was to improve
productivity that is getting the farmers
to produce more and better food well how
did they do this well that's exactly
what we're going to look into right now
[Music]
the University of vaga Megan you've
probably heard this sentiments a
thousand times Silicon Valley wouldn't
be what it is today if it weren't for
Stanford University it's the mecca on
research for everything that has to do
with electronics and telecommunications
but they don't only do research they
also train the best computer scientists
in the world and when those could be
dishonest sleev the university they go
directly to big companies like Google
Apple and Tesla well as far as
agriculture is concerned the Macra of
innovation isn't actually in the US but
it's in the Netherlands we're talking
about the University of bargaining and
also known as food Valley many of you
might not have heard about this
University that's because the only work
in the world of Agriculture
they don't have degrees in law art
history vaga noggins motto is to improve
food quality for the entire world so you
might be wondering right now what's so
special about this university well the
first difference is money the
Netherlands knew that they needed
technology to improve their farming so
well what did they do well they showered
their scientists with money in just two
decades the university's research budget
doubled but hold on just a moment
because money is not the only important
thing here the truth is the most
important thing wasn't how much but
where the money was coming from
you see in many European countries and
in most of Latin Americans a very clear
line that separates public and private
universities public universities are
funded from the state of course they can
have some sort of collaboration with
private companies but that's not their
main source of funding long inning in
this case is different
fifty percent of their money comes from
the government twenty five percent from
the university's own income and the last
25 percent from private companies and I
can probably guess what you're thinking
right now private company is funding a
university does this mean that the
university is private now well no but it
does bring a great advantage it allows
the university to be connected with the
rest of society
[Music]
when we were preparing this video we had
a phone call with a farmer called C's
Bravo in Spain
more specifically he's from the Canary
Islands and we asked you about how
agricultural modernization works now you
might not know this but livestock is
actually very important in the canary
islands especially goats they have a
specific type of go there called the
Palma goats which is unique from any
other breed in the world there are
actually several institutes and
foundations dedicated to studying this
specific type of goat
however as Cesar explained practically
none of the studies are actually useful
to farmers
[Music]
I mean think about it if you have a goat
farm what kind of research do you really
need as a farmer you want to know how to
produce more and better milk studies on
how to better feed the animals dietary
supplements or even genetic engineering
are useful well if you go to the I CIA
website for example which is the Canary
Institute of agricultural research you
won't find anything like that
there are tons of academic articles that
explain the breed origin of the Parma
goat whether it's related to other goats
in Morocco or Tanzania or if they
existed during the Middle Ages practical
usage that kind of zero meanwhile
according to The Times Higher Education
ranking bargaining and studies are the
most cited in their fields but that's
not all
I bet you can't guess what the
university's official languages given
that it's in Hollands you'd probably be
thinking they would be speaking Dutch
right well no not at all we're talking
about the capital of agricultural
research here and because of this more
than 40% of the students and research
staff are foreign
no matter where you're from if you have
a talent in agriculture you can get a
place at this University
record numbers foreign students at Dutch
universities of Technology because of
this international makeup the official
language of the university is English
that explains why at bargaining and is
for example a pioneer in LED lamps for
greenhouses which allows for the
creation of precisely control to
artificial micro climates thanks to this
the Netherlands is one of the leaders in
tomato growth even though in natural
conditions tomatoes would never grow in
such a cold country and there's more
here in a country like the u.s. farmers
need about 126 liters of water to grow
one kilogram of tomatoes well thanks to
this University's research now one can
produce the same amount with just eight
liters of water this is an incredible
amount of saving in both economic and
ecological terms but hold on a minute
here because research is good but it
isn't really worth anything if it stays
within the university and in that regard
the Netherlands is again a great example
of how things being done right
[Music]
from the university to the field let's
get back to Spain for a moment imagine
that we have a tomato garden and we want
to invest in this hydroponic technology
that will allow us to save water the
European Union or more precisely the
Common Agricultural Policy provides all
kinds of grants so that farmers can
modernize their fields so we'll go to
the Agricultural Extension agency where
all of these grants are managed so the
farmers get their money there and then
they will make sure that they spend it
on improving production techniques so
far so good but how do farmers know
which machines to purchase one would
think that the farmer would know better
than anyone what their lands would need
but the truth is that the agricultural
world evolves as quickly as internet
companies and if nobody advises the
farmer they'll have to find the
information out themselves well that's
the situation in which almost every
Spanish farmer has found themselves
there's a huge gap between the
University and the field the Dutch case
though is entirely different in the
Netherlands they have the so-called
agricultural council offices that means
that there's someone there who will
explain to the farmer what type of
machine they need to buy and what
technologies are best suited for their
type of crop
[Music]
and what's the result of all of this
well Dutch fields look nothing like
those in any other country while most
European countries consume tons of
antibiotics for their animals the
Netherlands farmers are already using
the most advanced veterinarian
techniques in such a way that they can
prevent diseases instead of curing them
the same happens with plant pesticides
in this country they noticed that if
they use drones to monitor the crops
they can control each and every one of
the vegetables and prevent them from
becoming infected and in the country
where almost half of the crops are
irrigated they have managed to decrease
their water consumption by almost 90
percent further agricultural product
exports surpassed 92 billion euros last
year and not only that Holland is also
making money by exporting their
technology the United Arab Emirates goes
Dutch to ensure their food security
[Music]
so the question now becomes do you think
other countries can import these kinds
of policies how far can the technologies
developed in Holland go to feed the rest
of the world well leave your answer in
the comments below and before we finish
I'd like to thank Cesar Bravo and Andrew
gar go from a GQ Nutrition for helping
us with this video and if you're
interested in this subject will soon be
releasing another video explaining the
common agricultural policy that we
mentioned in this video in depth also
don't forget to visit our friends at the
reconsider media podcast they provided
the vocals in this video that well not
mine and as always do remember that we
publish brand new videos every week so
hit that subscribe button and you won't
miss a post and if you like this video
give it a thumbs up and as always I'll
see you next time
and if you want to learn more about
politics and here even more of my lovely
voice you can join us at reconsider
media we have a podcast at reconsider
mediacom slash podcast see you there
[Music]